[Music]
the wall's upside down right now
[Applause]
[Music]
where do we start hello and happy the
falcon and the winter soldier week yes
it's officially called that now you know
after the one division finale i feel
like having that week off to rest up and
get those theory-busting chops back in
action
is just what we all needed and when i
say action
baby i mean action the falcon in the
winter soldier is flying onto screens
this friday
but before we start our weekly recaps
you should know
that you gotta subscribe make sure you
don't miss out on those i'm carlos
bustamante
and here is a spoiler-free edition of
everything you need to know
about the latest disney plus series
what's going on in that cyborg brain of
yours you don't want to know
oh yeah i can see it working gear's
turning
oh they're malfunctioning they're on
fire god i hate you
okay so right off the hop you need to
address this show was supposed to be the
first
marvel foray into phase four initially
slated for august 2020 the pandemic hit
of course moving a long list of mcu
properties back and we were gifted
instead
with one division now as we know from
episode 4 of that series
the events that happened in west view
came about three weeks following
the blip now all eyes are on the dream
team of sam wilson aka falcon and bucky
barnes the winter soldier
both snapped away during avengers
infinity war and presumed dead for five
years before returning for end game
the guys are going to have to
re-establish themselves as living
persons
similar to what monica rambo had to go
through when she returned
we saw a bit of this transition
explained in spider-man far from home as
well but maybe we'll get even more
clarity on what that's like
in this series following the events of
endgame how involved
are sam and bucky with the avengers it
seems from the trailer the pair are
teaming up to give america hope
but what does the team look like
specifically in a post endgame world
maybe
um you know maybe not today people need
something to get behind
you know what we can all get behind just
a lot of fun with the vibranium bros
are you stronger connected now than you
ever have been before do you
we're still obviously not because
sebastian knows nothing about me
[Music]
it's an evolving relationship like all
of the base
the best great hollywood marriages yeah
two people are two people constantly
evolving yeah evolving
anthony you said sebastian knows nothing
about you but like he doesn't know your
favorite song
he doesn't know your favorite movie
nothing i don't want to i don't want to
bring it up i don't want to harsh i
don't want to harp on old stuff
we're evolving sebastian i don't want to
bring it up again but what's anthony's
favorite sandwich
[Music]
but he's never he won't come to new
orleans so he wouldn't know
that it's a shrimp po boy dressed with
extra pickles and hot sauce
i just know that anthony drinks his um
protein shakes with whole milk
all right and he's playing the real
man's drinks
are you having a staring contest
just blank sweet jesus okay so aside
from who won that syrian contest
the one big question fans are hoping
this series will answer is
who the f is going to take over for
captain america language
sorry cap force a habit uh star anthony
mackie has revealed on multiple
occasions
that as of right now his character sam
wilson has not accepted the role
despite what old man cap had to say on
the matter how does it feel
like it's someone else's
it isn't cap
decided he was going into retirement and
he asked me if i would take up the
shield
but at no point in time did i agree to
or say that i would be captain america
so as mackie explained on the jeff cagle
show back in january sam is conflicted
about this decision and from what we've
seen so far
the us government is as well appointing
john walker aka the super patriot aka
the u.s agent
the updated captain america role over
sam
the character played in this series by
wyatt russell is based on the marvel
comics anti-hero who was initially
presented as
a foe to the captain america we all know
and love and for a while
became his replacement obviously with a
complicated comic book past
the assumptions will come that he will
undoubtedly be involved in some shady
business in this series but
i mean we all thought the fisto was
going to show up in one division and did
he
did he well maybe he didn't we just
missed it i mean the theories are
still out there the legacy of that
shield
is complicated
will walker fight with sam and bucky
before potentially teaming up against an
even bigger bad
maybe possibly someone like oh i don't
know
uh this guy superheroes
cannot be allowed to exist
ah yes helmut zemo played wonderfully in
the captain america films by daniel
bruhl is back
and this time he brought his purple
balaclava with him which is very
fetching now
traditionally zemo is the bad guy he has
a long complicated lineage in the comics
and this series could very well dive
into that
and maybe even his forgotten claim to
the sokovian baron
he but there is a scene in the trailer
where it looks like he might be working
with the falcon in the winter soldier i
think there's more to this relationship
than me it's the eye
okay now let's talk about that shot for
a second the setting there has been
pretty much confirmed to be the island
city of madrid poor
and you know who's known to hang out in
magipur this guy
to be fair pretty much every major
marvel comics character has shown up in
magic board but the place
has a very strong connection to the
x-men and i just i mean
can we just get the x-men back soon
please
here we go again huh emily vancamp's
sharon carter
captain america's niece now
is back short catch up on her she was on
the run at the end of captain america
civil war and was also counted among the
missing during the five-year blip
could she have found nick fury and
joined up with sword could she have
somehow
found her way back to shield other
actors who we know are back because
well i am db george and pierre will be
returning as batshock the leaper which
i'm sure will lead to some awesome fight
scenes
breaking news on et canada i took a full
punch to the head from gsp
and took the punch and didn't get
knocked out true story
we have footage of it anthony you have
too many
stories of people accidentally punching
you i know
it happens a lot man it happens a lot
and don
cheadle will also return his war machine
although not much is known
about his involvement new faces to the
mcu are
uduje as sam's sister sarah wilson and
aaron kellyman rivaling zemo for best
faceware in the series
who will play carly morgenthau leader of
the flagsmashers
in the comics carl morgenthau was an
anti-nationalist who became the original
flag smasher
to violently promote his agenda it was a
mantle taken up by several different
people though
not all at the same time the mcu's flag
smashers look like a legit threat
to our dynamic duo hello girl kick your
ass
so are you excited for the falcon and
the winter soldier you know
i'm going to start with the theories
very soon
will zmo's involvement somehow lead to
the formation of the thunderbolts will
either sam or bucky eventually become
captain america
is sharon may be a little pissed that
her boyfriend is
kind of her uncle now yeah i know
alternate timelines but
come on if you've got some before we get
started drop them below in the comments
and i'll see you on friday for the
[Music]
premiere